the success of the film change your
career in your life oh
wow you know it it comes and trickles
and ways always being a character
actress uh work is is is up and down but
it it's certainly a lot of people have
seen the movie and uh so I'm getting
some more auditions than I had been
before getting to meet some new people
so the residual uh trickle down
hopefully we'll get work as long as I
get more work I'm a happy to right again
so much depth to your performance and
the we of the pie did you find legy how
did you kind light it up when you guys W
shooting you know I um I'm one of those
actresses where my mom said I like to be
joyous and just sort of hang out with
everybody and with this particular
project it was a little tougher uh uh I
grew up in East Tennessee originally
I've been gone for years but there's a
similarity between the folks there and
any of those rural Pockets that you find
um but you know when you're on a set
with Jennifer Lawrence and John C and de
grck it was a big happy family everybody
was just joyous so we uh we had fun when
we weren't shooting and uh that kept
this level when we
were the
movie character is a m somebody that
needs and now this a war what this a war
as a
Woman movie cont oh wow um well the
award is is is is is beautiful it's it's
a real thrilled to be honored by this
community uh there's so many wonderful
filmmakers and I think this whole movie
itself was so strong with women with uh
all of the producers and directors the
writers the Stars so I I share this
though with the women of Missouri there
was so many wonderful you saw the film
locals in the film that opened up their
part
and to
this no absolutely not it's been a crazy
lovely Lely ride you know we knew that
people were enjoying the film and
embracing it but we had no idea that
that it would have this life so it's
been a a lovely wonderful Whirlwind and
I've just been enjoying the
ride
the lead oh Jennifer's a deer she's
she's every time we see the film I'm
more and all of her performance and uh
she's grounded she has a great family
and uh going to have a great
career is so collaborative did anyone on
the crew such as a costume designer help
you in your process of
developing you know just pretty much
everybody it's very collaborative our
costume designer actually uh uh carart
which is a big Outdoor Company you know
they traded she got some car heart
material that she would go into the
families and give them new clothes and
they would use their old clothes so that
just just the feel of the clothes in the
camp but the one family whose property
we filmed on mostly there were a couple
of women that were very mer life uh so I
observed them a lot and spent a lot of
time walking around the property was a
great fils are never although yes you
know um I do know that Gran had anyone
and everyone involved from Missouri she
had them read the novel D wood Noel so
that they understood the subject matter
and what she was trying to do with it
and they gained she gained their they
gained her trust she she they knew that
she wanted to make an authentic film and
I think the people of Missouri in that
area are very proud and very excited
about what's done they recognize it in
their Community as well as a lot of
communities around the
country
you don't know it's okay i' I've been
around a long time but I do a lot of
episodic television I have recurring on
my name as Earl I play the daytime
hooker which
most a little different uh but at
Sundance Dan got behind this film early
on and I think without they embraced it
and pushed us forward so I'm very
grateful to
them I think he did I didn't get to meet
him though but first of all
congratulations said it's hard to find
jobs as a character act myself would you
would you give me some
advice don't compare yourself with
anyone else if you love it keep doing it
if you don't cut R thank
you all right thank you so
much I wish that I return